[Music]
in sweet revenge news Oh submitted by I
loved a barbell brigade Oh a man took
revenge on his noisy neighbors by buying
a building shaker and leaving it on all
weekend holy [ __ ] how do you buy a
million shaker I need to find out what
the [ __ ] that is amazing just shake a
building yeah what's the permit as I can
build earthquake why does it shake the
building and why does it shake it well
maybe it is to test it for like
earthquake preparedness [ __ ] really
I don't know I'm guessing hmm it
probably is that it's probably not
someone was like somebody's going to
want to shake a building like a market
for this yeah can we get this on Amazon
you know what's so funny like I'm so
dependent on Amazon I get disappointed
in Amazon when it doesn't have a thing I
want to deliver it yeah they have
everything but when they don't have much
time yep
you know so what happened to the
building did the building what happened
to the guy like didn't he go crazy trow
get a chainsaw and all right so it takes
place in China oh of course
so apparently there was this um man that
the surname is sow sow sow sow sow sow
was complaining about his absurd
neighbor's kid because it's kid their
kid just kept running around making all
the noise oh he was being a kid you
[ __ ] little kid yeah be a kid when
you let me roll up little kid welcome to
another she was actually approaching
them you know like asking like politely
late you know you don't do this you guys
are kin allowed can you please keep it
down and they just I don't care okay
yeah okay about you know problem is that
he's a Chinese kid and since all Chinese
kids know kung fu he wasn't practicing
the tip toe touch
ah he was causing a lot of noise here's
a thing called the tip toe touch yeah
like they're every Chinese kids know you
know how to walk on water so it's the
Postpile you like make really really
quiet but he wasn't practicing yeah I my
shaky will you [ __ ]
yeah so he went online he discovered
this product is this shaker helping
shakers yes I mean just Google that how
thousands of sectors it's just that up
of apartment like we write on a behavior
say looking up there doing it yeah so
then he left for the week all there was
yeah so he turned it on he left for the
weekend and the neighbors are going
crazy they kept calling like to build
the proper position off and they
couldn't do anything they're just like
well we just have to wait until your
neighbor gets back home which is kind of
strange to me because it's like if you
own the property don't you have access
to every monthly if you like shaking it
right here to see come on man I think
I'm talking like this
I'm so sorry there's nothing I can do
for you I can you help us but how do
they know it's like what do they like
called the neighbor must have put a
building shaker in his room was back
like why are they not apparently they're
saying that from like from the man the
man who actually put up the building
shaker it just sounds like a low hum of
an air conditioner but for the people
upstairs is just constantly shaking it
like was a sighs John was a she was it
like a big block building like with ten
stories and I'm not sure what the
building looks like mostly on them on
the room or in the ceiling and it's like
they have different models so I'm not
sure exactly which oh that one's the
building shaker by [ __ ] funny
cute when he finally got home he was
like he's like [ __ ] yeah a sweet revenge
oh yeah then he turned it off but not
it's not clear if there were any
consequence of watching and wait how
long was he gone for for two days
straight Oh little eagle did shake a
building exactly as though but imagine
he's coming there and come down like a
house of cards like laughs yeah oh I
didn't begin drew I want a building
shaker now I wish and you look up how
much that cost they still are they
saying that the one that he bought you
bought it from four hundred yuan so that
that equals about $58
you want maybe these are meant for a
deeper time now I'm Deena oh look for
building shake that the Amazonas visa
was the Chinese won a huge opine about
Alibaba no we go listen to Bing bow know
you're kind of close because this
gentleman that they link is a taobao's
I'm a close
it's a suitor company because I'll
[ __ ] around [ __ ] pal primed Papa has
never had really noisy neighbors ages we
are they are the noisy neighbors
yesterday we had somebody over were
chopping things with an axe and he
chopped it on a spray paint can and
she's like not completely chopping just
a little hole on it so oh and got paint
all over the neighbor's car dank
underground hot pink spray paint just
went but she it was just raining on
their deck and on their car apologize
that what do you do yeah we apologize
and I mean I got all the paint off the
car luckily like we got there quick
enough it wasn't totally dry I have a
blister on my finger from just going
like like all these little dots and then
we got paint thinner for the driveway
which they don't even know about it
no they know they know they don't mean
them there was denial Airbnb I just
failed I left anything like all in one
box get back in a fix this but then we
got paint Center for the driveway and we
did it and it got rid of all the pink
but it's just I don't know if we like
them clean it up properly because it's
just black now it's like we tarred part
of their driveway but I was done
anything yet see some opponents dead but
it's noob Dogg's cousin so he's cool
Bobby another time we were doing a
Facebook live where we're blowing
balloons like soccer ball or blowing
balls so so much air into the cup low so
we had we all thought it was blow it up
they explode hard a beach volley
American football and a soccer ball
no sudden we see a police chopper above
us said wow is that for us wonder how
long it's going to take till the cops
pull in and then somebody goes oh no
they're already here and there's six
cops coming in from like the neighbor's
yard and they got handsome they're like
guns they're wearing a speedo and
American food
well thank you geared up when I'm
talking a yoga ball like this and they
thought it was just shooting
yeah our neighbors thought it was they
were gone because they're going ah
they blow so hard the volleyball I was
like 30 feet away and I felt it on my
chest like when it's like it blows hard
and plus we all we knew is going to be
kind of loud so we all - earplugs so
that - everyone's like don't what the
cops are here like what like on the
communication wasn't even happening plus
as a helicopter like there's a mess
there's a great live broadcast they said
you should probably let your neighbors
know next time we're going to do
something like this so they never saying
that like getting murdered
it's crazy so you guys have never
experienced in anything resistors you
Beaman we have never experienced I don't
think they know what that's why yeah
yeah wondered I would love to have a
noisy neighbor pressure on up even with
what we do about what my family's like
my kids are so loud it I call it noise
pollution I go home wife keeps just
talking screaming there's Darth Vader
Carmen there's Elsa singing you know let
it go
and when the night comes everybody kind
of forces they I start screaming quiet
it is I can't talk by the way dozen
spiders back where were oh it is on two
different one if they want smaller
oh there's probably like thousand
through that [ __ ] is [ __ ] huge
hey guys how did you guys like that JK
news episode well let us know by liking
the video for more videos click right
over here
you